bonsoir alors oui je suis venu vous
parler ce soir d'un mot un mot que tout
le monde connaît un mot très simple en
quatre lettres un mot anglais mais qui
commence à être d'usagé courant dans la
langue française c'est le mot ce lot
alors on va partir de ce qu'il ya dans
votre tête parce que ce mot évoque
quelque chose à chacune chacun d'entre
vous donc je vais lancer une toute
petite séance de ce lot pour les nuls en
quelque sorte en faisant un qcm de base
alors le slot pour vous est ce que c'est
une danse langoureuse entre amoureux qui
ne se pratique plus de temps que ça
malheureusement le farniente c'est à
dire le style de vie des paresseux ou
bien une course d'escargots la bonne
réponse est faux aucune de ces réponses
n'est bonne
toutes ces réponses appartiennent à des
clichés des caricatures du passé ça
c'était bon au 20e siècle
aujourd'hui en 2015 le mot slow évoque
bien autre chose de beaucoup plus large
de beaucoup plus globale ça évoque un
mouvement mondial qui est né à la fin
des années 80 en italie avec le slow
food qui s'est très vite répandue aux
quatre coins de la planète à la fois une
lutte contre le fast food et le retour à
des valeurs de tradition dans le domaine
culinaire et gastronomique
aujourd'hui ce mouvement compte plus de
120 mille ans des rangs à travers le
monde
c'est devenu l'un des principaux
mouvements associatifs mondiaux et il a
produit plein de petits il a créé plein
d' avatar dans différents domaines
d'activités alors il ya eu le slow
travel vous le voyez ici on allait
slow cities mode de gouvernance slot
pour les responsables de ville je ne
vais pas me la met on a le slow sex on a
le slow cosmétiques
enfin il ya eu plein de mouvement slow
et tant et si bien qu'on a même commencé
à voir apparaître des sommets du slow
living un ou des symposiums de la slow
life ici et là et puis le dernier né et
ça c'est le livre que j'ai eu le bonheur
de faire paraître en janvier de cette
année c'est le slogan jeunesse puisque
le business c'est le dernier endroit où
on attendait le slot c'est plutôt un
monde qui semble en contradiction avec
cette idée cette notion mais il semble
en contradiction parce que l'on véhicule
encore avec nous ces caricatures du 20e
siècle
alors je vais faire un tour d'horizon
pour vous montrer qu'on peut l'envisager
le comprendre d'une nouvelle façon et en
particulier dans le monde du travail
dans le monde professionnel puisque des
chefs d'entreprise des entrepreneurs ont
été suffisamment fou suffisamment
innovant suffisamment créatif pour créer
des méthodes de travail de gouvernance
et de management
ce lot est en plus oui ça marche il ya
de nombreuses success stories que je
décris dans mon livre qui le prouvent
donc ce n'est plus une ce n'est pas une
affaire de ravers il ya des cas concrets
mais pourquoi cette explosion ait cette
multiplicité de ce lot depuis vingtaine
d'années et bien à cause de ce que je
considère être un malaise de
civilisation qui va de pair avec ce que
de nombreux contemporains aujourd'hui
ressentent et vivent comme une perte de
maîtrise temporel depuis que mon livre
est paru je suis allé dans nombre
d'endroits g assurer des interventions
des conférences des ateliers des tables
rondes j'ai été interviewé je m'y
attendais pas du tout et j'ai été
confronté à énormément de gens qui me
disent parfois d'une façon très désolé
ou dramatiques
je suis débordé je n'y arrive pas
je ne sais plus par quel bout le prendre
mon rapport au temps est catastrophique
et c'est alors pourquoi
d'où ça vient ce constat ce premier
constat il vient d'un autre constat
qu'on peut faire en trois points
d'abord nous avons vécu pareil ces
dernières décennies et puis plus
particulièrement plus intensément ces
dernières années une multiplication des
outils technologiques alors ordinateur
laptop téléphones portables smartphones
webcams gps
j'en passe et des meilleurs les montres
connecter le mouvement va continuer le
mouvement va continuer on nous promet la
révolution domotique qui de fête
commence à se mettre en place
la révolution connectique avec tous les
objets connectés de fait ça commence à
se mettre en place
donc ça va être encore plus demain un
exemple d'innovation récente en août
2014 des chercheurs suédois ont réussi à
mettre au point une nouvelle fibre
optique high tech de nouvelle génération
un essai a été fait qui a prouvé que ça
marchait avec une vitesse de
transmission de données de 43 tetra
bytes par seconde
les connaisseurs apprécieront c'est
énorme ça veut dire que ça va à nouveau
accéléré la vitesse de transmission
demain et après demain et c'est pas fini
deuxième point est la multiplication des
outils de diffusion et de partage de
l'information
donc avec vous connaissez tous les
facebook et linkedin
les nouveaux médias aussi les réseaux
sociaux les youtube même nouveaux médias
web et le huffington post etc etc
ils se sont multipliées ils forment une
espèce de nébuleuse dans laquelle on a
un peu de mal à se situer désormais il y
en a beaucoup en at il trop une question
en tout cas un constat a été fait c'est
que un occidental était soumis en l'an
2000 environ un certain nombre
d'informations en moyenne par jour
et en 2015 10 15 ans après il est soumis
à dix fois plus d'informations il faut
gérer ça
comment fait-on nous ne sommes pas
habitués nous devons donc réinventer nos
modes de gestion de l'information dans
le temps un troisième phénomène est venu
avec tous ces phénomènes s'ajouter se
croisent et s'entrecroisent et ce à des
phénomènes de transformation de nos
moyens de transport avec là aussi une
accélération permanent des vitesses de
plus en plus importante
ça a été la voiture ça a été les avions
ça a été les trains les avions à
réaction
les trains à grande vitesse ce mouvement
est loin d'être finie je donne un
exemple en 2050 devrait avoir lieu le
premier vol commercial d'un avion de
nouvelle génération un supersonique
développé actuellement par
l'aérospatiale ça s'appelle le zeste il
volera à mach 4 c'est-à-dire la limite
de la vitesse super tonus supersonique
quasiment dans l'hypersonique nous
permettra de faire paris new york en
1h30
paris tokyo en 2h30 et paris sydney en
3h30 à l'autre bout de la planète alors
l'accélération vous le voyez est loin
d'être finie alors une fois qu'on fait
ce constat est ce que c'est bien ou
est-ce que c'est mauvais si c'est une
bonne ou une mauvaise chose et bien les
deux à la fois c'est une bonne chose
parce que ça améliore quand même nos
modes de vie faut être honnête je vous
donne un exemple
moi quand j'ai commencé ma carrière
professionnelle en 92 pour aller
négocier avec un responsable au japon
sur un contrat par exemple important
bah il fallait prendre l'avion alors
c'était 15 heures pour y aller puis il y
avait le temps de séjour il fallait 15
heures pour revenir et ça a coûté
beaucoup d'argent on perdait du temps de
l'argent c'était assez compliqué
l'époque ça paraissait pas à compliquer
sa part et c'est normal aujourd'hui elle
plus besoin de faire ça vous vous
branchez avec les moyens de
vidéoconférence qui se sont démocratisés
comme skype et l' affaire est réglée
donc un vrai gain de temps et d'argent
donc
du bon al'inverse comme on a commencé un
peu à le comprendre à le cerner on se
sent de plus en plus challenge est de
plus en plus pressée cerné de toutes
parts tout le temps partout ces nouveaux
outils technologies de diffusion de
partage d'accélération et c est donc ça
c'est une nouvelle aliénation de nos
modes de vie une aliénation que certains
spécialistes certains chercheurs
certains universitaires commencent à
appeler du nom de time poverty et oui la
pauvreté est aussi temporel je vous cite
une petite anecdote dans les antilles
françaises
pas seulement française d'ailleurs il
est de coutume de croiser des gens sur
la plage qui nous disent ah oui mais
vous les européens là bas les
occidentaux sur le continent vous avez
la montre mais nous ici on a le temps
alors c'est vrai que ça fait sourire
mais c'est de plus en plus vrai c'est de
plus en plus exact ont-ils gardé quelque
chose que nous avons perdus lorsqu'ils
nous interpelle de cette façon là eh
bien il d'une certaine façon oui nous de
nous subissons une sorte
d'empoisonnement de notre temps par tous
ces nombreux facteurs que nous venons
des mines et d'énumérer et donc il faut
détoxifier notre temps désormais il faut
le des emplois zone est en quelque sorte
et donc lorsqu'il ya un poison pénètre
un corps voudrait comme moi il faut un
antidote est donc une antidote qui
devient de plus en plus pertinent de
plus en plus criant c'est le slow comme
on l'a vu ça explique pour la raison
pour laquelle ça se multiplient comme ça
c'est multiplier alors le slow c'est
quoi cette deux clés de clés de mots
clés la décélération et la
détoxification la décélération c'est pas
la lenteur pour la lenteur s'est ré
introduire un peu de lenteur
là où il n'y en avait plus de façon à
retrouver une certaine incertaine
équilibre temporel de façon à assainir
notre rapport au temps
certains spécialistes parlent et j'aime
bien cette expression de lenteur
maîtriser dosée et puis c'est la
détoxification de notre temps la lutte
contre un certain nombre de facteurs qui
tendent à empoisonner notre temps alors
ça se manifeste de façon relativement
concrètes par un certain nombre de
méthodes ou d'outils donc ils commencent
à apparaître j'ai essayé d'en faire état
dans mon livre une de plus des outils
des boîtes à outils slot pour leurs
applications au quotidien
alors je n'ai pas le temps de vous les
citer tous il y en a beaucoup je
pourrais en citer deux ou trois fois
plus souvent je vous en présente et 6 le
premier c'est que nous venons du xxème
siècle où il y avait une croyance
dominante c'est que la vitesse maximum
était une condition de réussite pour
gagner fallait être le plus rapide mais
nous avons découvert que c'était souvent
une fausse croyance en tout cas une
fausse croyance lorsqu'elle était la
seule on a redécouvert la notion de
rythme
le rythme c'est une équilibre entre des
temps courts des temps longs des temps
rapides et des temps lent et ça semble
être la bonne clé pour réussir non
seulement réussir dans les affaires mais
réussir dessous tout simplement dans sa
vie personnelle
les musicologues le savent bien parce
que la notion de rythme évidemment chez
les musiciens chez les musicologues
c'est important alors je vous cite le
cas d'un allemand un piano un pianiste
virtuose qui s'appelle ou klimt qui a
fondé en allemagne un mouvement qui
s'appelle le tempo giusto qui est en
fait le mouvement slow dans le domaine
de la musique en particulier delà de la
musique classique
que dit il il dit il est stupide de
boire du bon vin trop rapidement il est
stupide de jouer mozart trop rapidement
je récuse cette notion très moderne qui
veut que le plus rapide est toujours le
mieux
le mieux est le tempo giusto le temps
juste
un deuxième outil c'est la
chronobiologie alors nous sommes tous
des horloges ambulante mieux que ça nous
sommes tous des magasins d'horloge
ambulante
il ya plusieurs horloges internes
physiologique qui jouent en nous à
chaque instant partout où nous sommes ce
cet homme ce professeur d'université qui
est chercheur et enseignant à
l'université de surrey en
grande-bretagne s'appelle yann dijk
c'est un spécialiste en génétique
il a travaillé sur le gène per 3 et il a
découvert que ce gène déterminer si nous
étions plutôt c'est pas absolument
catégorique sont des tendances lourdes
plutôt des hiboux ou des alouettes alors
un ebook est ce que c'est un hibou et
bien c'est un lève tard et un couche
tard quelqu'un qui va plutôt être
performant et efficace en fin
d'après-midi ou en début de soirée ou
même la nuit et une alouette celle
inverse c'est un lève tôt et un couche
tôt quelqu'un qui va plutôt être
performant le matin nous découvrons que
nous sommes conditionnés par la
génétique dans ce domaine là également
donc de nouveau nous mettre devant notre
miroir et découvrir découvrir peut-être
à tâtons se fait de façon empirique
notre profil chronobiologique et une
fois que nous l'avons découvert nous
devons le respecter pour le valoriser
parce que sinon nous allons ramer à
contre courant de notre identité
chronobiologique si par exemple nous
sommes du matin et qu'on nous fait
surtout travailler le soir alors un
exemple de mise en application parce que
ça a trouvé des mises en application
concrète
cet homme serge cousin est un patron du
nord
le patron fondateur de l'entreprise
c'est iv qui était une entreprise de
génie climatique qui s'est reconverti
dans les green data centers
c'est un vrai homme d'affaires nordiste
il dit le droit du travail nous impose
des horaires collectif mais chez nous
nous avons amine aménager les horaires
d'arrivée en les étalant entre 7h30 et
9h30 de façon à ce que chacun puisse s'y
retrouver
ceux qui veulent arriver plus tôt pour
repartir plutôt ce qu'ils veulent
arrivée plus tard pour repartir plus
tard et de surcroît nous faisons
attention au créneau sur lesquels nous
sommes performants pour tous nos
collaborateurs
moi par exemple je suis peu performants
voire pas performant du tout entre 14h
et 16h gelé remarquer et bien c'est un
créneau pendant lequel je me refuse à
traiter des dossiers ou des négociations
importantes parole de ce lot business
men ou plutôt de sage peut-être tout
simplement
autre outil la lutte contre les
interruptions
toutes ces nouvelles technologies tous
ces nouveaux outils cette nouvelle
diffusion d'informations tout le temps
partout en permanence nous sollicitent
chaque sollicitation est une possibilité
d'un terreau de nous interrompre dans ce
que nous faisons
une étude a été faite aux états unis
auprès d'une population de cadres qui
prouve que lorsque nous sommes en train
d'effectuer une tâche de façon
concentrée si nous nous interrompons
pendant une minute
il nous faut 23 minutes de récupération
pour revenir au même niveau de
concentration
donc c'est important il ya un grand
patron américain jason fried qui dit
nous journée et sont assaillis par les
interruptions à nous de la défendre donc
on la défend en travaillant en bloc
temporelle des blocs où on se concentre
sur ce qu'on fait on évite de se laisser
interrompre par des facteurs extérieurs
et ensuite on gère les interruptions les
appels sms les blip blip et cetera
une fois qu'on a fini de se concentrer
sur le bloc temporel c'est un peu lié au
point suivant le point suivant c'est
notre capacité à effectuer des tâches
avec deux modes principaux multitâche ou
mono tâche alors êtes-vous multitâche ou
mono tâche qui se sent plutôt multitâche
oui pas mal demain quand même la très
grande majorité des personnes qui
viennent de lever la main ont tort
ça a été prouvé scientifiquement par une
étude l'année dernière en californie
il a été démontré que seuls 2
pour cent de la population était
réellement capable de fonctionner sur le
mode multitâche et donc nous sommes 98%
à fonctionner sur le mode mono tâche à
savoir
je reprends mon illustration des blocs
temporel bloc après bloc
là nous sommes efficaces alors vous
pouvez toujours croire si vous êtes
monotâche dans les 98% que vous pouvez
fonctionner en mode multitâches mais
vous prenez le risque ça a été étudiée
de perdre jusqu'à -40 % de productivité
et puis un autre dispositif un autre
concept intéressant c'est entre les
tâches entre les blocs temporel il ya
des intervalles la gestion des
intervalles est un point extrêmement
important pour prendre une analogie avec
le corps humain là on a une main sur un
levier de vitesses et bien une main
comme tout le corps humain est fait de
partis duré deux parties molles et entre
les deux il y à des articulations et
bien les intervalles sont à notre temps
ce que nos articulations sont à notre
corps devon c'est ce qui est accordé une
importance particulière comment les
gérons nous qu'en faisons nous est ce
qu'on en fait quelque chose est-ce qu'on
passe d'une tâche à une autre tâche à
une eau d'une tâche à une autre ça c'est
la pire chose à faire
la gestion des intervalles souvent
considérés comme des temps morts doit
devenir une opportunité de les vivre
comme des temps vivant je conseille
vivement je suis pas le seul là aussi ça
a été ça s'appuie sur diverses études
qui ont été qui ont été réalisés
d'essayer de les transformer le plus
possible en des temps décalé où vous
faites ce que vous ne vous autorise
auriez pas à faire habituellement
alors vous vous préparer un thé ça peut
être très courts un intervalle ça peut
être une deux trois minutes ça pas
besoin d'être une pause de 20 minutes
vous préparer un thé vous passez à un
coup de fil à un ami que vous n'avez pas
eu au téléphone depuis bien longtemps
vous envoyer ce fameux sms qui traîne
depuis des semaines voire des mois et ça
s'accumule avec tous les autres vous
sortez et vous allez faire un tour dans
la nature pour vous reconnecter à des
choses un peu scène vous écouter un
morceau de musique qui vous fait plaisir
après quoi vous pouvez repartir sur une
autre tâche et vous avez inspiré ce que
si vous êtes toujours dans l'expiration
comme dit le bon vieux proverbe à vous
mourrez quoi comme dit le bon vieux
proverbe français
à force d'être trop tendue la corde fini
par casser et c'est très vrai de même
pour passer d'une vitesse à une autre
vous remarquerez il ya un petit temps et
un petit intervalle
donc c'est une réalité c'est une loi de
la physique et une loi de la nature
dernier concept slow dernier outil si
vous voulez le contrepoint temporel
alors il faut commencer par comprendre
que nous raisonnons de façon souvent
inconscientes parfois de façon
consciente avec des unités de temps on a
été câblées comme ça dès le plus jeune
âge alors il ya cette grande unité du
temps avec lesquels nous jonglons tout
le temps c'est l'année le mois la
semaine le jour
la demi journée l'heure et la minute
prenons la plus grande unité temporel
prenons l'année il est très important
d'introduire dans cette unité temporel
là mais en fait ça vaut pour les autres
un contrepoint personnellement je prends
chaque année deux à trois jours de
retraite spirituelle au vert et donc je
vais oui dans une cabane au fond de la
forêt ou dans un monastère ou sur un
lieu isolé près de la mer ou dans le
désert je m' extraits de mes conditions
de vie habituel jeu m'extraire de mes
routines temporel habituel de mes
habitudes temporelle pour vivre quelque
chose de totalement différent et je le
fais en mode zéro technologies et bien
c'est une occasion de prendre une pause
c'est une occasion de prendre du recul
c'est une occasion de remettre les
choses en perspective
c'est une occasion de faire une
relecture de nos parcours qu'en est-il
de l'année écoulée qu'est-ce que j'ai
vraiment vécu d'importants de fort des
difficiles de beaux de réjouissant de
compliqué je fais le point g clair si
toutes ces questions là qui sont
importantes
ça redonne de la direction et ça redonne
du
sens donc c'est vital donc on le voit
bien je pourrais vous donner d'autres
outils mais ça suffit je crois pour
faire comprendre que le slow est un
antidote ralenti notre à deux à deux
titres
c'est un antidote à titre individuel on
le sait les burn out se multiplient je
considère que introduire un peu de ce
lot un peu de philosophie slow dans nos
pratiques
aujourd'hui c'est devenu absolument
nécessaire c'est un anti burn out de
première classe
c'est un antidote un niveau systémique
parce que notre civilisation notre
société une système dans lequel nous
vivons vous l'avez vue continuent
d'aller dans l'accélération la
multiplication et c'est moi je suis sûr
que si on continue comme ça on va droit
dans le mur
donc c'est un antidote comme anti crash
du système et donc c'est notre avenir
est donc le slow oui on comprend qu'il
soit devenu important et je pense que
c'est loin d'être fini
pour conclure le mot de la fin je le
donne à quelqu'un qui ne peut pas être
soupçonné ni de fainéants tease ni de
parti pris activiste par rapport au
mouvement slow puisque il s'appelle
frédéric arnaud under c'est l'un des
plus important homme d'affaires de
scandinavie c'est un multi entrepreneur
à succès suédois qui a fondé et
développé un groupe qui s'appelle qui
broker qui fait plus de 500 millions de
dollars de chiffre d'affaires et il a
été repéré par le cabinet deloitte comme
l'un des hommes d'affaires les plus
rapides du monde puisqu'il a connu sauf
erreur de ma part en 2012 je suis pas
sûr mais je crois un taux de croissance
de son chiffre d'affaires de plus 800 88
%
et bien c'est cet homme là c'est cet
homme là se fasse businessmen a priori
qui écrit dans son dernier livre we all
lieders paru malheureusement en anglais
pas encore traduit en français récemment
il écrit osez être lent vous accomplirez
des choses étonnantes avec du temps je
vous remercie